i've been wanting to make a video on a
couple of terms that people have really
thrown around for a while now and i
think it really hits the core of some of
the issues we're dealing with now with
the credit debacle but it's kind of at a
at a at a deeper level so the things i
want to go over the ideas of
savings
savings consumption
consumption
and investment
and you hear these a lot everyone
obviously says i've invested in the
stock market or i've invested in a house
and i really want to give you a
a framework for how i think about these
ideas and frankly i haven't seen them
depicted this way in in any economics
book although they've kind of touched on
this but i think this is really how you
should think about these things
so if you save money you know and i
think we all know what that means that's
money that you didn't spend there's a
couple of things that you can do with it
you can either consume your money or you
can invest your money so let's just
think about a bunch of different
situations and think about whether those
things are consumption or investment
so let's say let's say i have uh i don't
know it's a hundred thousand dollars
that i'm i'm dealing with
so let's say i take that hundred
thousand dollars and i
build a factory
i build a factory
and i think that that factory is going
to be able to produce i don't know i'll
make up some product it'll be able to
produce cars more efficiently and
cheaper than any other car factory out
there
well i think this we would all agree
that this is this is an investment
and why is it an investment
because i'm taking this hundred thousand
dollars
and i'm putting it to some use that is
creating hopefully more value than my
original one hundred thousand dollars in
fact i'm expecting some type of a return
on this investment and i've made a bunch
of videos on what a return on investment
is and you can usually quantify it right
if i take a hundred thousand dollars and
i build this factory and this factory
spits out fifty thousand dollars a year
it's probably creating at least fifty
thousand dollars a year of value
assuming that nothing corrupt is
happening in our system in fact it's
normally creating more than fifty
thousand dollars a year of value maybe
creating a hundred thousand dollars a
year of value fifty thousand of that
maybe is going to the person who's doing
the production and then the other half
of the value is actually going to the
consumer of of whatever uh this factory
is making and you have to think about it
because if all of the value went to the
person who produced the factory then
there's not a huge incentive for someone
to use its products anymore but anyway
that's not the topic of this discussion
we're just trying to get a a mental
framework on what consumption is versus
investment so i think we all agree that
if i were to if i were to build a
factory that this is let's say i'll do
everything in green as investment
so building a factory is
an investment
now let's say that i
um
i don't know i'm i'm homeless i'm
homeless and i have this hundred
thousand dollars and because i'm
homeless i don't have a place to go and
eat dinner and rest and relax and
because i don't have that i can't get a
job and i can't become a productive
member of society so maybe i'm going to
use this hundred thousand dollars to buy
a simple house that meets all of my
needs so let's say build a simple house
and i'll do that in a neutral color
build
build a simple house
simple house so this is my other use of
this hundred thousand dollars instead of
building a factory i'm going to build a
simple house and this house it provides
shelter for me and my family it allows
us that that kind of security that now
my kids can go to school
and they can themselves become more
productive citizens i now have an
address i can um i have a place to take
a shower that allows me to go get a job
and i can now create value for society
as a whole instead of being you know on
the corner and and begging for money
from people i would argue that this is
also an investment why is it because i'm
taking this hundred thousand dollars
that maybe i had or someone gave to me
i'm taking this hundred thousand dollars
and it's generating a return and what is
that return
well in a factory it's maybe a little
easier to quantify but at minimum it's
this work that i'm able to do because i
now have a house because i have the
security i have the address i have the
shelter i'm able to relax
it's that security and it's also the
return that probably my kids are going
to be able to
now contribute to society maybe if they
grew up homeless they would have never
been able to contribute and now that
they had a roof over their head and
they're able to go to school et cetera
they are able to give some economic
value back to society it's hard to value
you know maybe i didn't have any job
before and now i have a job and i can
contribute thirty thousand dollars a
year to society maybe i'm working at
someone's factory uh maybe i'm providing
some other maybe i'm a farmer now
whatever i'm providing some sort of
value and maybe my kids if they never
got an education they would have you
know been maybe they could have made
added ten thousand a value per year to
people and now they can add twenty
thousand value so that difference would
also be some of the return on this
investment so i also consider this
to be an investment
now my question to you is let's say that
i already had a house this is an
investment
let's say i already had a house and my
family is happy and
we have everything we need we have food
on the table and my kids go to school
and i'm able to get a job and all of
that exists but let's say i still have a
hundred thousand dollars and i use that
hundred thousand dollars i'll do it in
yellow again another neutral color
and let's say i use that hundred
thousand dollars to put some uh granite
countertops
granite countertops i have some money
left over let's see i'm gonna add a
bathroom
add a bathroom to my house
and
i will i don't know i'll put the latest
hardwood floors just so that i'm
so that my family will be impressed
hardwood floors and and you can imagine
and maybe i add i add 2 000 square feet
you normally can't get all of that for a
hundred thousand dollars but i think
you'll bear with me
so i'm essentially doing some major home
improvements so my question to you is
this an investment or is this
consumption
now in our everyday world the way with
most people we deal with they will call
this oh i've invested in my house and
why are they saying that because they
say by spending a hundred thousand
dollars in in the house in this way that
maybe you know if you've watched um the
home and garden channel they're doing
this all the time that if you know if
you if you pour this hundred thousand
000 into your house then maybe the value
of your house is going to increase by
150 000 or someone else all of a sudden
is going to perceive the value of your
house as being
you know 150 and they'll say well you
got a 50 000 return on investment
i'd argue that that is not investment
that is speculation you are essentially
piling money into this stuff and i'll do
this in red consumption is in red
so this is consumption consumption is
red
what's happening here truly economically
when you add granite or you add an extra
bathroom or hardwood floors this extra
2000 square feet is it making anyone
who's living in that house more
productive is it making you harder
working is it making you more likely to
invent um the cure for cancer are more
likely to invent a way of getting cheap
energy or um or or or produce more
widgets no it's it's just if anything
providing more things for you to have to
take care of that you're not going to
focus as much on your work or more
energy is going to have to be expended
to maintain this type of place i mean to
to heed and cool a 2 000 square foot
house so if anything
by actually pouring the hundred thousand
dollars here you're actually creating
something that is going to suck more out
of society in fact in no way is this
going to contribute to the collective
wealth of society the last two examples
i gave contribute to the collective
wealth of society some of which you
share and that is your return on the
investment but as a whole this is an
investment into society and it's going
to create a
it's going to make the pie bigger
this right here does not make the pie
bigger it might make you a little bit
happier make your ego feel a little bit
better uh let your let your pride grow
and your self-righteousness grow and and
show other people that you've arrived
but it's not going to increase the
wealth of society and when you say that
you've invested you're really just
saying i've speculated i what you're
saying is by paying this hundred
thousand dollars you're going to find
essentially a greater fool out there who
you know before they could have done the
same thing they could have bought your
house spent a hundred thousand dollars
and done this if this is what would have
made them happy but what you're saying
is essentially
that you're gonna find somebody out
there who's willing to pay a hundred
fifty thousand extra dollars for
something that should have only costed a
hundred thousand dollars and if anything
if you use this at all the value of this
is going to go down so you're just
somehow assuming that and you're
assuming that the granite countertops
that you choose are going to be the
taste that someone else would like or
that the hardwood fours are going to be
the taste that someone else is like i
would actually argue that when you
customize your house in this way you are
you are creating a hundred thousand
dollars of consumption to your taste and
i would be surprised if someone else
truly is willing to pay
more than a hundred thousand dollars
unless they are being in some way
irrational or they can finance this
because it's being it's part of the the
mortgage anyway this is i think you know
just the big picture
investment adds value to society
investment a simple house adds value to
society consumption is something where
you people might call it an investment
because it's kind of speculation it
might
find some other guy who's willing to
emotionally pay more for something but
it is not in any way it's money that's
burned it's not creating more value for
society i'll continue this in the next
video